foreign
last summer I was in New York and had a
conversation that had me thinking ever
since I met Mubarak Imam one of the
early engineers at whatsapp and what she
told me changed how I look at migration
she said to me Johan I will never forget
the first time I walked into the office
at whatsapp it felt like a mini United
Nations and she explained to me that it
was precisely that Global diversity that
made them design the app not just for
the average U.S college kid in mind but
for a truly Global audience and in that
process they asked questions few others
would like does the app work in the more
rural parts of Africa Asia and elsewhere
or will it work for a refugee on a boat
sending a message back home to their
family
the rest is history
WhatsApp became product fit for the
world and chances are you like me might
be using it every single day
of course WhatsApp is not just an
outlier
look at Chachi BT fisa biontec vaccines
Google search YouTube the iPhone the
list goes on
each one of these pretty remarkable
products was built by teams of
immigrants and locals working creatively
side by side
and that's why leading companies today
they don't just Outsource
internationally to save money on cheaper
labor they do that but what they also do
is that they hire immigrants for their
insights experiences and unique
perspectives
there are 280 million International
migrants in the world today and many
more up to 750 million people say that
they would move internationally if they
could I lead our research on global
migration here at BCG a global
consulting firm and I also advise
governments and companies on Innovation
and migration strategy outside of work I
call lead a team of more than 100
volunteers we are Imagine and we're a
community of talent Without Borders
and every day we help skilled migrants
from places like Afghanistan Syria Egypt
Pakistan Nigeria or elsewhere we help
them find a new job abroad come here and
integrate into your new life and from
these experiences I can tell you these
280 million people they aren't just
statistics
they're real human beings with families
dreams and hopes of a better future
yet too often when they relocate
they're met with fear Prejudice or even
outright violence
yet in my mind migration does not have
to be a zero-sum one game where one
person wins and the other person loses
no if we look at it differently it can
actually be a source of great strategic
Advantage both for companies and entire
countries
we looked at this recently in a joint
Report with iom the International
Organization for migration of the United
Nations
and in that report we published two
headline figures
one migrants already today create a
massive boost to our local economies
totaling 9 trillion US dollars a year in
2020 and that impact will only increase
to 2050 to 20 trillion US dollars a year
and what's more migrants can help us
address pretty acute labor shortages
that we see in our economies
because it turns out we don't have lack
of jobs in many countries we tend to
have a lack of workers and that lack of
workers it costs all of us dearly 3
billion US dollars not per year
per day that is doctor appointments not
happening packages not delivered or
flights back home being canceled
so how can we make migration work better
for everyone that's exactly the question
we looked at when we recently
interviewed 800 Executives in recent BCG
survey and what they told us really
surprised me because 95 said Johan we
see the value in hiring globally but
only five percent said and yes we're
already doing it strategically and we're
getting the results to show for it
so companies seem to struggle big time
to follow the lead of WhatsApp and
others and when we dug deeper and
wondered why we initially thought it was
a Visa issue but then we took a closer
look at the Visa policies of more than
25 countries and we found that with the
exception of the US and China all the
other countries actually give a pretty
direct path to entry for work if you
have a bachelor's degree have a job
offer and make just a little bit more
than the average salary in the country
all of these conditions can be quite
easily fulfilled by recent University
graduates with just two or three years
of work experience
so the Visa process could it be faster
and easier at times absolutely yes but
this is the showstopper that keeps
talent and opportunity away from each
other clearly not
so what is it then if it's not a Visa
issue caused by government bureaucrats
in my view
the issue lies in the world of business
and within all of us and that's actually
the good news because it means that we
can all change it changing it starts
with senior Executives because like any
other business priority it must come
from the top or it ain't gonna happen
let's take a look at Rakuten for example
Rakuten is a Japanese e-commerce company
that by now has expanded globally but in
2010 the company was totally Lost in
Translation translating documents across
English and Japanese and back on a daily
basis losing days of work and also
making it pretty hard for Global Talent
to join the company so the founder and
CEO of Mickey mikitani he stepped up and
issued a decree he basically said from
today on all meetings presentations down
to the canteen menus they must be in
English
sounds easy is not so for the next few
weeks absolute chaos ensued and for sure
you can imagine was a pretty stressful
transition for many Executives not home
in English as their first language but
over time the decision paid off and the
company turned from a formalistic
hierarchical one into one that is much
flatter and more decentral and if you
visit the offices today you will see
people that migrated to Japan from
places like Bulgaria France Germany
India Indonesia and elsewhere and since
then the company has expanded into 30
countries and is seen as the poster
child of a modern digital and Global
Japan one senior executives are on board
human resource teams are next in the
past these HR teams they could afford to
basically just write a local language
job description and hire from a talent
pool largely 50 miles around the
headquarters today not so much in
leading HR teams for many positions they
actively hire
let's take a look at douglas douglas is
Europe's number one Beauty retailer with
more than 1 800 stores across more than
15 countries yet in the pandemic they
had to close many stores and they made a
hard turn towards e-commerce and they
knew that in order to do that they had
to dial up their Tech teams yet they
really couldn't find the tech Talent
here at home in Germany so to fix that
they did two things one they introduced
a fully remote digital hiring process
complete with hard and soft skill
assessments and they also launched a new
hiring campaign called the code behind
the beauty in order to attract a more
Global diverse set of applicants since
then they've hired a QA tester and
product Managers from our imagine pool
and they're also brought hiring more
globally and hired developers and for
other roles completely internationally
and as a result they managed something
pretty rare for an offline retailer and
that is translating their offline
strength into true online growth
potential and the cherry on top doing
all of that by following the latest and
freshest HR best practices that benefit
not just foreign workers but all of
their talent pace
finally let's look at you and me and all
of us who don't work in HR teams and
don't lead global companies just yet so
the next time you're hiring for one of
your teams ask your HR colleagues to
maybe also shortlist a couple of global
candidates
and when you interview them be ready to
be surprised a couple of months ago I
spoke to a group of female developers
from Afghanistan seeking a career abroad
and yet despite the unimaginable horrors
of their daily lives and the Injustice
that they are facing they actually
brought a degree of positive focus in
skill and creativity to the
conversations I could only deeply admire
yet frankly in other circumstances it
turned out differently and people were
clearly not mentally or culturally ready
for Life abroad over time I personally
learned to check my own biases at the
door and I'm still working on it
but let me give you an example when
people address me by email as esteemed
sir or doctor I don't immediately cringe
or think that there might not be
culturally ready no I learned over time
that they only mean it as a sign of
respect
yet let's face it the culture Gap is
real and it can always help to get some
culture coaching
in fact I'm a culture coach myself
sometimes in my own family
so a couple of years ago my brother
Jonathan was applying for a job in the
US as a research scientist and initially
he was struggling just a little bit so I
took a look at his emails and I could
tell he was writing them from a very
German mindset let me give you an
example he wrote something like dear Dr
Smith
I'm writing to you in relation to my
previous letter from April 22nd I
haven't heard a reply from you since
true story
it's not just too formal it's a
borderline Rude by American Standards
even though in Germany believe it or not
you still might get away with it
so I told him to rewrite his emails in a
more global standard something like Dear
John I hope you had a great weekend I'm
following up on my blah blah blah you
get the message
and with that and because it's great he
got the job and what's so unique about
this is he did not have to learn a new
skill spending years on it all that it
took was somebody pointing out to him
the small but significant changes in the
way he presented himself
and now after a couple of years he's a
great culture coach himself and in fact
I think that is something we can all
aspire to because migration is indeed
one of the great possibilities of our
lifetimes one that we can all contribute
to
and one that clearly has in business
so-called first mover advantage and
that's why I predict that companies who
embrace the most Global most educated
generation ever they will win in the
marketplace While others who still stand
on the sidelines they won't I call that
Global Talent advantage and it applies
as much to companies as it does to
entire countries
I think it's time that we change
perspective and see migrants not as a
threat or as a burden but as an
opportunity
an opportunity to build more vibrant and
Innovative Nations and also an
opportunity to do our little share to
make the world a better place for all
thank you